got gosling huh i bought this shirt
i look very hetero everywhere i go now
i'm just kidding i'd suck this guy's
dick
only god forgives the true story of
jesus christ
kidding this movie has nothing to do
with god god i don't think
likes this movie this movie is an insult
to everything biblical i
actually really loved it it's [ __ ]
weird it's trippy it's hypnotic
certainly not for everybody okay but the
number one thing i appreciate about this
is because it's written and directed by
nicholas wynden refin the director
of one of my all-time favorite movies
drive
look another picture of ryan gosling god
the balls on him here's what i love
about it you could tell this guy had
complete
control over this film i love the tone i
love the imagery behind the
cinematography
absolutely beautiful magnifical for some
reason i'm doing these italian hands
today the whole time it just felt like a
dream
a weird violent dream you just felt like
violence could go down
at any given moment from beginning to
end even though it's not filled with
violence but don't get me wrong when
it's violent
it's violent it is sometimes really sick
sometimes sometimes people walk out of
the theater
when something is just a little too
nasty and they weren't expecting it
like the three old i'm assuming jewish
people that left the theater
i just loved the way it was executed
it's like the anti-movie structure from
the trailer you think you're gonna get a
simple movie about
ryan gosling going out there and seeking
revenge on the people who killed his
brother
please know nothing like that it is told
completely weird this film is just weird
it's trippy
it's [ __ ] strange as [ __ ] strangest
things i've ever seen in a movie have
happened in this film
and that's why i appreciate it so much
because this guy obviously made the
movie
he just really wanted to make i felt
like he had a dream
and was like [ __ ] look at everything
i just dreamed about on the screen it's
wildly unique fascinating as ever and i
can see why it's not for everybody
because it goes against almost
everything we say works in a movie
doesn't make it bad though they don't
make stupid moves
and of course the number one reason i
saw this movie ryan gosling
yes yes yes yes yes yes i'm going to
give a hint here
soon i'm going to do an episode of top
10 dicks i like to suck he's in the top
three
anyway ryan gosling really liked him in
this everyone's like he's doing the same
performance he didn't drive
no he's not watch the [ __ ] movie
again and you'll see he's not doing the
same thing in try
he he's very you know you're more
sincere there's a lot more
sympathy this guy just seems like a
complete emotionless psychopath like he
seems confused
lost and you feel like horrible things
happen in his childhood and he does a
great job of portraying it he's not
exactly the person you relate to but
he's fun to observe you would not want
to [ __ ] with this guy
no no you feel like he has the
capability to just rip your penis off
with his bare hands
which i know will not happen with us
another great performer in this movie
kristin scott
thomas wow this has got to be the
freakiest mom i've ever seen portrayed
on the screen
you get hints that she probably sexually
abused her children but you don't know
for sure so you can't hate her for it
because they don't really make it clear
for you yet but
regardless of that she says some really
obnoxious things the c
word is the most common word she uses
not cat
no not that word
[ __ ] anyway she goes far beyond a
judgmental mother she's like the mob
boss
of this crime family and uh she's very
controlling you can totally see why ryan
gosling is the way he is and the two
complement each other's performances
quite exquisitely and another another
great performance in this movie the
scary asian guy
the guy who plays the cop the antagonist
of the film this dude
no whoa don't want to meet him in real
life i don't want to commend him because
he's so good at it
that i actually believe this is what
this person's probably like in real life
he's old
yet you feel like he can kick your ass
at any moment and not in some crazy kung
fu way
he has a sword and apparently he likes
to chop off people's arms
i don't know why but it's a thing he
likes to do i
it's it must be some type of eroticism i
don't know but one thing about these
performances that i love
there's not a lot of talking in this
movie and i think people are just not
getting this film in the film like
these guys they communicate mainly
through body language and expression
and yes there's not a lot of talking so
people are like oh they're thinly
written performances
i don't think so it's very apparent
these actors were all on the same page
all knowing what's going on in each
other's minds and they're able to
communicate a film so well
where you can tell what they're thinking
and feeling without them having to say
a single [ __ ] thing isn't that
impressive
you're gonna write that book brian how's
that nova coming
huh go to beginning middle and then go
to protagonist
some of the score not all of the score
but some of the score fantastic you know
nicholas winning rep and really good at
picking good composers for his films too
bad i don't remember the composers names
what i will say
i'm not gonna give it away but the last
five to ten minutes has some
weird [ __ ] that goes on
where you're like why the [ __ ] did this
happen i don't know how to react to this
how did it just get to this point so
suddenly in such a creepy fashion and it
almost ruined the entire movie for me
but you know like if i just block that
part out of my mind and remember
the first 80 minutes fantastic just
great time for the last five to ten
minutes
oh god don't don't get it i just don't
understand it if you
if you're able to time the movie just
turn it off before you reach that point
it makes no [ __ ] sense
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say only god forgives
got it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my show why don't you go ahead scroll
that comment box below
and tell me what did you think of only
god forgives did you hate it
and can you tell me what the hell the
last five to ten minutes was about and
if you want to go ahead and follow me on
twitter you can click the link right
here
tweet me i'll tweet you back we'll look
cool together
maybe we can go out on a date male or
female female preferably
male maybe depends on your body
candidate fat guy and if you want to see
a more in-depth review of only god for
gives
go ahead and check out my show called
reasons to see and we have special
guests on the show michelle q
she is mexican there are no mexicans in
thailand that is what i learned
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time a new review is
out go ahead and click on this button
about my penis to subscribe
that's right people people penis
sounds kind of similar doesn't it
i can tell you god forgave me because he
blessed me with this thing